a school in Fort Lauderdale Florida
within a bunch of hot water after a
teacher
reportedly banned one of her students
from reading the Bible
during pre reading time she actually
called
the parents a phone at home and left a
message and we've got money
first
funny kept
I just I'd
ok cash-strapped
cast
first
art direction to I coaxed
fast call
free
I okay so this brings up a lot
interesting things obvious about freedom
of religion in this was free
reading time at the school which implies
that the kids can read anything that
they wanna read
now I know you guys are a huge on
religion
so I thought this would be an
interesting topic for you guys to handle
what do you make of them
best teacher it was in a school-wide
thing apparently but this
teacher felt that this kid could not
read the Bible in class is that
okay no i i don't think that's okay I
mean
I'm normally very against having
religion in schools but that
having the school push religion on the
kids in this case the kid just with an
individual
who wanted to bring the book to school
read it and it's a personal choice and I
don't think that should be
handle the way that they did you know
Cara personal choice
well I mean yeah the first amendment and
protect my right to not read the Bible
the same way protect this child right to
read the Bible this is a blatant
violation of the Constitution
and there's a you know there's action
being taken now their lawyers that are
working with the
with that student's family and this
could potentially be pushed up through
the court system
though I'm not sure if this teacher is
aware of the fact that she's violating
the Constitution by telling this child
that he can't read this book in her
classroom and maybe
that'll be corrected as soon as she
kinda remove the Constitution yeah
like that can read the Bible is gonna
influence the other kids around them
you never know it's not being forced to
anybody even if it didn't want the other
kids around him it doesn't matter
because
the truth is that is a a choice that
our like the law of the land protect
though this wasn't something that was
like you that part of the curriculum
this is that something the teacher was
pushing on to the students but yes you
have every right to read whatever
religious text you want to read in a
public place in a private place whatever
it be one thing if he was reading this
book when you're supposed to be reading
Tom Sawyer and reading a big stink about
it but in free reading
class to tell us to do that yet to take
bilateral glasser
his career and out of the classroom his
store out of the classroom whatever is
yeah it's a violation of the First
Amendment yeah I don't like carrying
around a correr it or is mad
I think the bigger bull it's very likely
that the huge thing I can tell you the
thing it kinda
Indian in israel like that there are
giant bibles 0 I'm rather like in
Arcadia
I people pushing her away and I will
forget up to kids bibles armaan other
yeah I got a million others liked stupid
Bible at are you right now at about the
site
but um should we be a little afraid
a so what we're blaming it on the
teacher not the the school itself so
that that's when the but should we be a
little afraid of these people that
are pushing the at the religion thing
even if you're not for
religion in the public sphere that
they're pushing it to this extent like
that she called she said
you know this isn't gonna happen in my
class that there's a there's a danger
really in her methodology at how she's
trying to preach
liberalism absolutely i mean there's as
much of a danger there
other is pushing religion on kids you
don't wanna make up their mind for them
it should be up to the child as we were
saying before
yeah so yeah I mean I don't love it
child can really make those kinds of
decisions I mean that's another
that's another debate entirely but aside
from that I i think we need more contact
like sheep
reaching anti-religion or she so afraid
a First Amendment violations and afraid
of all the things that she's been in the
news lately that she thought that this
was the right course of action like
oh no I don't a Bible in like classroom
because I could get in trouble for that
maybe Lake that's the thing is that when
you become very extreme on one side or
the other
the issue I think and because it's such
a polarized issue it's such a political
kinda
hot-button issue I think that there's
confusion surrounding and this
again we don't we don't have contact it
could be that this woman was trying to
push
a specific agenda it could be that she
was afraid up the opposite agenda being
you know it seeming like it's being
pushed in her class arms up I think with
a little more context we would
understand it a little better but until
then it kinda hard to tell yet where you
guys following terms a
love where'd where the debate should be
on this because there is so it seems to
me
you could teach in history class you
could teach about the historical
existence of Jesus and what was going on
in that time
without giving a religious context to it
but should but you want to start doing
that then you open up a can of worms
where everyone wants to
bring all the the miracles and all that
in it so we're waiting for in terms of
what we can teach without
teaching a mere so obviously there's no
viable evident that Jesus actually at
all
maari
yeah I already wrote a book about the
historical
yeah go yeah plays halo their their
their stories there's you no
corroborating
like tales and myths and and and maybe
nine minutes we don't know but there's
no
there's no actual evidence that there
was a historical figure in Jesus the way
that there's evidence of historical
figures
who you know wrote things or where we
have you know their bone
someplace like that that doesn't exist
for for Jesus Christ so
so and I'm not saying I don't think
Jesus Christ existed I have no fucking
idea
but I don't think they want empirical at
my one pair left hand there's absolutely
nothing wrong with talking about the
history of religion and history
philosophy in those types of courses I
don't know it
like jesus's existed should be time in
history class
record I don't think we should be making
I mean the sorry that is that the
distinction that should be taught the
purity in high school for example should
be taught in social studies
but it could be taught in in a velocity
yeah there's a lot to be there electives
you can choose to take religion you can
have Bible study classes
outside at the high school mean but you
can't just sit there and say that I know
Jesus was historical some a teacher but
you can teach the affects
that religion had a history man it's
important to carefully avoided yeah
that's going to be part of your history
class regardless if you're learning
about kinda American history or if
you're learning about world history like
you can't avoid a conversation about
religion
but I think religion as an institution
and its sociological effect is a very
different conversation
then the lower and the dogma within a
religion being taught us
backed like that that's where I start to
charge actually existing in and having
political
you know Mac an Asian thing like that
that's real the a walk on water stuff
emad yeah
well we're all agreed that part in my
has did not know what I am going nowhere
near scientific Riki with some that when
a pretty well